c'est une décision qui a provoqué une
nouvelle fois la colère du peuple
libanais 7 me ils étaient plusieurs
dizaines dont de nombreuses familles de
victimes à exprimer leur mécontentement
la cause la récusation du juge fadi
sawan chargé de l'enquète sur les
explosions au port de beyrouth
c'est une honte pour eux de gt nos
droits comme ça nous espérions que les
juges sawan trouverait la vérité pour
nous je veux qu'ils ne soient pas
effrayé nous sommes avec lui
vraiment nous sommes avec lui même s'ils
sont puissants nous le sommes encore
plus avec les familles des martyrs nous
soulignerons que l'éloignement de fleurs
10 à one est un autre crime
ajouter aux crimes de l'explosion du
port de beyrouth un crime d'empêcher un
testament et la décision judiciaire
et c'est totalement inacceptable une
révocation qui jettent encore plus le
trouble sur la classe politique
libanaise et sur des soupçons
d'ingérence dans le système judiciaire
libanais une véritable parodie de
justice selon de nombreux habitants et
certaines ong qui dénoncent des
pressions politiques sur l' enquête en
cours
l' enquête du juge sawan posait de
sérieux problèmes et il avait peut-être
des raisons légitimes de contester sa
nomination mais le fait qu'il ait mis en
accusation des politiciens n'en fait pas
partie les tribunaux ont montré une fois
de plus qu'ils protégeront les
responsables politiques contre toute
reddition des comptes aux dépens des
citoyens
un nouveau juge va devoir être nommé et
devra relancer l' enquête
mais maintenant les lignes rouges ont
été fixés il ne faut pas inculper les
politiciens le 10 novembre dernier
fadi sawan avait décidé d'inculper pour
négligence plusieurs éminentes
personnalités politiques libanaises
parmi elles l'ancien premier ministre
hassan diab ou encore ali hassan khalil
égaliser à iter à l'origine de la
demande de récusation
ces derniers étaient respectivement à la
tête du ministère des finances et du
ministère des travaux publics et des
transports
quand les deux mille sept cent cinquante
tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium avait été
stocké en 2014
dans le hangar numéro 2
du port de beyrouth fort d'un soutien
quasi unanime de la classe politique
libanaise
ils avaient tous décidé d'ignorer les
convocations du juge
une démarche appuyée par le ministre de
l'intérieur mohammad famille
l'inculpation de hassan diab dans le
crime de l'explosion du port est une
injustice et de la diffamation car il ne
faut pas faire assumer au premier
ministre le poids des suites d'un
dossier complexe qui remonte à sept ans
alors que le chef du gouvernement n'est
au sérail que depuis plusieurs mois la
classe politique libanaise est fustigé
par une grande partie de la population
du pays qui dénonce depuis plusieurs
mois sa corruption et son incompétence
un nouvel épisode qui risque d'aggraver
les tensions dans un pays en très grande
difficulté économique et qui fait
craindre un retour à la case départ dans
l' enquête sur les responsabilités liées
à l'explosion qui a touché beyrouth le 4
août dernier